ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, always being
somebody who wants to
get something for nothing, I
figure any time in this course
that we'll study the new
function, the very next thing
that we'll do is study
the inverse function.
In other words, since the
inverse is just a change in
emphasis, why not just change
the emphasis to get the result
that we want?
So you see, today's lesson
is called the inverse
trigonometric functions.
And the longest part of this
lecture will be a few
computations just to get
the feel of things.
The reason being that other than
that, everything that we
have to use will be drawn from
results that we've already
studied in our lessons called
inverse functions.
It's still the same idea, only
a different illustration.
Well, at any rate, let's get
on with the subject.
Let's start with the curve
'y' equals 'sine x'.
Now you see, when we plot the
curve 'y' equals 'sine x', it
doesn't take us very long
to discover that this
curve is not 1:1.
In fact, it misses
by a long shot.
Because for every 'y' value
between minus 1 and 1, there
are infinitely many values
of 'x' that produce
that value of 'y'.
This is an oscillating
type of function.
So you see from our rigorous
point of view, there really
isn't much sense in defining
the inverse sine function.
Well, in a way, this
is an artificial
drawback that we have.
Because you also recall that
when we talked about functions
that were not 1:1, we could
always break them down into a
union of 1:1 functions.
For example, notice in the part
of the curve here which
I've accented, namely, the
domain from minus pi over 2 to
pi over 2, notice that on that
domain, the sine is 1:1.
And it's certainly onto the
interval from minus 1 to 1.
In other words, every value of
the sign is taken on once and
only once on the interval from
minus pi over 2 to pi over 2.
So you see, if I disregarded
everything but this part of
the curve, and how
could I do that?
What shall I name
this function?
Well, why not do something
like this.
Let me invent a new name.
Let me call this curve ''s sub
0' of x' where ''s sub 0' of
x' is defined to be 'sine x'
provided that 'x' is in the
closed interval from minus
pi over 2 to pi over 2.
Again, be very, very careful.
Recall that when we talked about
defining functions, we
said that to specify two
functions as being equal it
was not enough that the function
machine was the same,
the inputs had to be the same.
In other words, two functions
had to be equal.
Or to be equal, the two
functions had to have
precisely the same domain.
So notice in this sense there
is a big difference between
''s sub 0' of x' and the
function that's being
called 'sine x'.
What is the big difference?
Well, for the function that's
called 'sine x', the domain is
all real numbers.
So the function called ''s sub
0' of x', the domain is only
the closed interval from minus
pi over 2 to pi over 2.
Now again, there's nothing
sacred about picking this
particular interval.
What I could have done was
define say, another curve,
which I'll call ''s
sub 1' of x'.
''s sub 1' of x' will be
the function 'sine x'.
But now, the domain will be
shall we say, from 3 pi over
2, or from pi over
2 to 3 pi over 2.
In other words, notice that this
portion of our sine curve
is also 1:1, and runs the full
gamut of values that the sine
can take on from 1 to minus 1.
And by the way, I
don't have to be
prejudiced this way either.
I could just have easily have
worked with negative values.
In other words, I could have
invented say another curve,
which I'll call ''s sub minus 1'
of x', where this subscript
simply means I'm going in
the opposite direction.
''s sub minus 1' of x' might
just has well have been what?
The curve 'sine x'.
But now again, how are all of
these things differing?
Only in the choice
of the domain.
See now the domain would be
from minus 3 pi over 2 to
minus pi over 2.
Again, in terms of the picture,
this portion here
would be fine.
You see what I can do is break
up this curve that fails to be
single valued by-- not
single valued.
Fails to be 1:1 by a
long shot, into a
union of 1:1 curves.
In fact, if I wanted to use
some fancy mathematical
language, which I'll
write down just to
look impressive here.
But if it bothers you,
ignore it completely.
I guess what I'm really saying
is, I could have defined 'sine
x' to be the union ''s sub n'
of x' as 'n' goes from minus
infinity to infinity.
Meaning what?
Take all of these pieces with
these integral subscripts and
form their union, and that
infinite union gives you back
the entire curve.
Well, what am I making
all this issue about
in the first place?
You see, we can't have an
inverse function unless our
original function is 1:1.
In fact, let's see
what does happen.
Remember how we invert
the function?
In other words, how do you get
from the graph of 'y' equals
'f of x' to the graph of 'y'
equals 'f inverse of x'?
Recalling from our previous
lecture on this topic, what
you essentially do, well, if
you're good at visualizing,
you just reflect with respect
to the 45 degree line.
If you're not so good
at visualizing, what
you do is, is what?
You first rotate this thing
through 90 degrees and then
flop the thing over.
And I've taken the liberty
of doing that over here.
I take my curve and again, this
would be very effective
if I had overlays and wanted
to slide these for you.
I think it's something that
you can see on your own.
So all I'm doing is what?
I rotate this thing through
90 degrees and then
flop over the result.
And now this curve will be the
graph 'y' equals inverse sine
of 'x' provided you can
have an inverse.
You see in the old math, this
was fine because multi-valued
functions didn't bother
us at all.
However, what is clear is notice
that in this particular
sense, the accented curve from
before becomes this little
region here.
And notice that the function
that I defined to be 's sub 0'
does have an inverse.
In other words, in terms of my
new coordinate system, I can
define what?
The curve 'y' equals the
inverse of 's sub 0'.
The idea being what?
That I cannot talk about
the inverse sine.
Now the reason I bring this up
is you'll notice that in this
text, in most every text, people
do use this notation.
And they get around it
in a rather cute way.
As you read the text you will
notice the phrase called
principal values.
Let me show you what
I mean by that.
What happens in the typical text
is they'll say look it.
By 'y' equals 'inverse sine
x', we mean that 'x'
equals 'sine y'.
But that 'y' is restricted to be
between the range of minus
pi over 2 and pi over 2.
This is called the range
of principal values.
Now you see, this sometimes
causes people to be a little
bit upset because why do you
have to make this restriction
since nothing here seems
to indicate that?
All I hope that you can see
from my discussion--
and this will also be written up
in our supplementary notes,
so if you need some
reinforcement from what I'm
doing in the-- not from what I'm
doing the lecture, but in
addition to what I'm doing in
the lecture you can get this
from the notes too.
But what I want you to see is
that what the average book
defines to be 'y' equals inverse
'sine x', and then
puts in the so-called principal
values, simply turns
out to be what I'm calling
''s sub 0' inverse'.
After all, what was 'y' equals
''s sub 0' inverse x'?
That would be rewritten how?
That's equivalent to saying 'x'
equals ''s sub 0' of y'.
But ''s sub 0' of y' was
defined to be what?
'Sine y' provided that 'y' was
in the range from minus pi
over 2 to plus pi over 2.
So far so good.
At least that's one
man's opinion.
What I'd like to show you now
is again, the beauty of what
inverse functions means.
That from this point on, I can
now, for example, in terms of
calculus, get every single
calculus result I need about
derivatives of the inverse
trigonometric functions just
by restating them in terms
of the ordinary
trigonometric functions.
For example, suppose somebody
were to say to me, find the
derivative of inverse sine of
'x' with respect to 'x'.
Again, keeping in mind now what
this means, otherwise I
don't have a function.
I have to have this thing
single-valued.
This thing does it for me.
Look it, do I know
how to find the
derivative of the sine function?
The answer is yes, I do.
We've already done that.
That was the last assignment,
in fact.
In other words, from 'x'
equals 'sine y',
can I find 'dx dy'?
Certainly.
'dx dy' is 'cosine y'.
Now, look it.
We didn't want 'dx dy',
we wanted 'dy dx'.
But since we're on a 1:1 strip
here where the inverse
function does exist, notice that
the relationship between
'dx dy' and 'dy dx'
is that they are
reciprocals of one another.
That was exactly one of the
nice properties of this
notation that we've
talked about on
several occasions before.
In other words, 'dy dx'
is '1 over cosine y'.
By the way, I like this better
than saying things like the
reciprocal of cosine
of secant.
I think when you print a book
people like to use secant
instead of 1 over the cosine
simply because you can get
everything on one line and
don't have to write
fractions this way.
But that is not a major
concern here.
What I do want you to see is
given that 'y' equals 'inverse
sine of x', can I find dy dx?
The answer is yes.
And by the way, notice
that this is
perfectly well defined.
Namely, for a given value of
'y', 'cosine y' you see a
single value.
For a given number, it
has only one cosine.
You see, I don't need
single-valuedness to get this result.
The place I have to be careful
about inverse functions
existing is that since there
are many different x-values
that correspond to the same
y-value, if I don't specify--
you see, if I have a
multi-valued function, if I
don't specify what branch I'm
on the trouble will not come
in when I'm looking for 'dy dx'
at a given value of 'y'.
It's that 99 times out of 100,
when you're looking for 'dy
dx', 'y' is given as
a function of 'x'.
In other words, you want to be
able to convert this in an
ambiguous way into a
function of 'x'.
That's the question
that comes up.
There is nothing wrong
with this answer.
In other words, I can write
down that 'dy dx' is
'1 over cosine y'.
But somebody can say
to me, I'd like the
answer in terms of 'x'.
By the way, how can I get this
answer in terms of 'x'?
That's an interesting
question sometimes.
Recall that 'y' equals
inverse sine of 'x'.
The same as what?
'x' equals 'sine y'.
Now what identity do I know?
I know that sine squared plus
cosine squared is 1.
'x squared' is 'sine
squared y'.
Now what do I know?
I know that 'cosine squared y'
is '1 - sine squared y'.
So 'cosine y' is plus or minus
the square root of '1 - sine
squared y'.
That's plus or minus the square
root of '1 - x squared'.
Notice by the way, in this
notation that 'y' wasn't any
old number. 'y' had to
be in what range?
'y' had to be between minus
pi over 2 and pi over 2.
And as long as that's the case,
notice that in that
range the cosine is positive.
That makes the negative
sign redundant.
And by the way, that negative
sign would not be redundant if
we hadn't restricted our range
to making the curve
single-valued and 1:1.
You see, it's the restriction
that 'y' has to be between
minus pi over 2 and pi over 2
that makes this the positive
square root.
In other words then, what
we see is what?
That therefore 'dy dx' is equal
to '1 over cosine y'.
That's 1 over the square root
of '1 - 'x squared''.
And that's a rather interesting
result.
It's a rather straightforward
I would like to make a few
comments about this thing.
And one of them is what I want
to summarize with later too.
Suppose you are given the
problem of saying, I would
like to trace a curve, or plot
a curve, and all I know about
that curve is that its
derivative at any point is 1
over the square root of 1
minus the square of its
x-coordinate.
Do you have to know any
trigonometry to understand
that problem?
In other words, notice that
this expression in no way
utilizes trigonometry.
Yet to solve this problem, it
appears from what we've shown
is that what?
That given that the slope is
this, the curve itself turns
out to be 'y' equals
'sine inverse x'.
And that is an inverse
trigonometric function.
And so here's a very important
reason as to why the
trigonometric functions
are that important.
The inverse trigonometric
functions.
Namely, inverse trigonometric
functions can
wind up as being what?
The inverse derivative of
a function which is
non-trigonometric.
And that's reason enough
to study these things.
Again, as I told you in my
last lecture, I was sadly
mistaken when I thought that
trigonometry belonged solely
to the surveyor.
I mean, look at all the
different places that this
material comes up in.
And if you don't like practical
applications, at
least observe that all we're
really doing here is
discussing inverse functions in
terms of function itself.
In other words, the result that
we've shown now is that
the integral of 1 over the
square root of '1 - 'x
squared'' is 'inverse sine
x' plus a constant.
By the way, since there is such
a connection between the
inverse trig functions and the
regular trig functions, and
since the trig functions lend
themselves to geometry rather
nicely, I thought I would like
to show you here a rather nice
device that allows you say, to
solve problems like this if
you weren't given the
answer in advance.
In other words, you'll notice
that in our problem by sort of
working backwards, we found
that the answer to this
problem was 'inverse
sine x + c'.
And the question is, what if
we hadn't been given this?
Is there a way that we
could've utilized the
knowledge of trigonometry,
classical trigonometry, to get
a hint as to how to do this?
And not only is there such a
way of doing this, but the
method turns out to be so
important that later in the
course, in the section called
'techniques of integration',
this comes up under the very
special name of trigonometric
substitution.
It works something like this.
Whenever you see the sum or the
difference of two squares,
think of a right triangle.
For example, in this case, if
I call the hypotenuse 1 and
one of the sides 'x', and call
this angle theta say, the
third side of the triangle
is the square
root of '1 - 'x squared''.
And now if I think of this this
way, what is the easiest
relationship that allows me
to express theta as a
trigonometric function
involving 'x'?
There are many trigonometric
relationships I can reach from
this diagram.
But it appears that the easiest
one is the one that
says 'sine theta' equals
'x' over 1.
In other words, 'sine
theta' equals 'x'.
And now you see from this using
differential notation
and the like--
and again, the technique will be
drilled into you and you'll
get plenty of opportunity
for using this in the
exercises in the text.
But for now, I just want you to
get to see an idea of how
the trigonometry does
come back into this.
Notice that from this diagram
I get this relation.
Now taking the differential of
both sides and notice that I'm
working with the ordinary trig
functions here, which I
allegedly know at this stage.
I also know from this triangle
that the square root of '1 -
'x squared'' is 'cosine
theta'.
Therefore, if I make these
substitutions in the integral
'dx' over the square root of '1
- 'x squared'', using the
differential notation 'dx'
becomes replaced by 'cosine
theta 'd theta''.
The square root of '1 - 'x
squared'' becomes replaced by
'cosine theta'.
These cancel.
The integral then turns out to
be what See the integral of 'd
theta' is 'theta'
plus a constant.
But what was 'theta'?
Theta was what?
'Sine theta' was 'x', so 'theta'
is the number whose
sine is 'x'.
Notice how the trigonometry
comes in and helps us to solve
a particular problem.
A particular problem that might
not have seemed that
obvious if we hadn't have
used the trigonometry.
And again, let me point out
where we've used the fact that
we're using 1:1.
You see, when we drew this
particular triangle, we
assumed that 'theta' was
in the first quadrant.
The angle could have been any
place if we're thinking of it
as an angle.
And knowing the sine only
determines the cosine up to a
plus or minus.
In other words, technically
speaking, this should've been
plus or minus over here.
But the fact that for principal
values 'theta' must
be between minus pi over 2 and
pi over 2, and since the
cosine is positive in that range
that was why we were
able to get rid of the
negative sign.
So again, all I want you to see
from this is the fact--
and this is very important.
That aside from the inverse
trigonometric functions being
rather important, we can study
them completely by giving a
short lecture because everything
that we have to
know primarily came from
previous lectures.
The hard part as is often the
case with inverse function
notation is that you may not be
familiar with the language
that rapidly.
I sometimes, when I was first
learning, had to think twice
about notation like this.
Let me start something
new here.
I'll start at the bottom
and work up.
When people wrote down
identities like this, I found
it very difficult to think
in terms of those.
What does this say?
It says that the 'inverse cosine
of x' is pi over 2
minus the 'inverse sine of x'.
And I couldn't remember why
that would be true.
Yet the funny part is, if I
let-- see let's go back to the
top now and start.
If I let 'y' equal 'inverse
cosine x' and tried to draw
what that really says--
see again, I have to be
careful about 1:1
and what have you.
But if I just mechanically
translated this,
this would say what?
'x' equals 'cosine y'.
'Cosine y' is 'x'.
That's 'x' over 1.
I've written it that way.
Well, look it.
If this angle is 'y', it's kind
of clear that this angle
is 'pi over 2' minus 'y'.
Now in this familiar
environment, how difficult is
it for me to see that
the sum of these two
angles is pi over 2?
You see, in that familiar
environment it's almost so
obvious I wonder why anybody
would want to
point it out to me.
Yet notice that from here,
how do I read this?
See what's another
name for 'y'?
In the angular system here,
'y' is that angle
whose cosine is 'x'.
It's 'inverse cosine x'.
What's 'pi over 2' minus 'y'?
'pi over 2' minus 'y' is that
angle whose sine is 'x'.
See notice that the side that's
adjacent to 'y' is
opposite 'pi over
2' minus 'y'.
At any rate, 'pi over 2'
minus 'y' can be named
'inverse sine x'.
And so from this simple thing,
simple because the language is
familiar to me, I get down to
the result that inverse
'cosine x' plus 'inverse
sine x' is pi over 2.
From which, of course, the step
here is a triviality.
See again, when we often deal
with inverses, one of the
fringe benefits that we have is
that when we get stuck, we
can always reduce the
given result.
Reverse the terminology so to
speak and return from the
inverse language to the
original language.
Now again, let me point out that
once you have a result
like this all the results
of calculus work
the same way as before.
For example, suppose somebody
says to me, gee, I wonder what
the derivative of 'inverse
cosine x' is
with respect to 'x'?
To be sure, I could go all
through this again and mimic
the results of getting
the derivative
for the inverse sine.
But notice now, by this result,
this is just the
derivative with respect to 'x'
of pi over 2 minus the
'inverse sine of x'.
But this is the derivative
of a difference.
And a derivative of a difference
is the difference
of derivatives.
And pi over 2 is a constant.
So the derivative of
pi over 2 is 0.
I already know how to
differentiate 'inverse sine of
x', I've done that before.
So I want what?
Minus that derivative.
I want 'minus 'd dx' 'inverse
sine of x''.
And that in turn is just what?
Well, I'll write it over here.
It's just minus 1
over the square
root of '1 - 'x squared''.
And again, another result
but obtained with a
minimum of new knowledge.
Now, I could go on but I think
that from here on in, it's
much easier for you to dig out
what you want on your own.
I had some other material that
I thought I would give you,
but I think that this will just
turn out to be a little
bit on the boring side now.
Not boring, but in the sense
that either you see what I'm
driving at or you don't.
And what I'd like you to do now
is simply to go and see
how much of this material
on inverse trigonometric
functions is yours now
free of charge.
If I have to pick one thing I
want to caution you about,
don't be upset by the language
called 'principal values' and
what have you.
Everything comes out in the wash
if you recognize that we
legally cannot define an inverse
function unless we
have a 1:1 function
to begin with.
So we must take the multi-valued
trigonometric
function and view it as
a union of 1:1 curves.
And then you see if you want to
pick a different principal
value, I think if you understand
what's happening
basically, you'll be able to
do this thing on your own.
In any event though, I think
this is enough on what we call
the 'inverse circular
functions'.
So until next time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.